joining me now Christopher rufo senior
Phil at the Manhattan Institute author
of America's cultural revolution who was
pivotal and kind of uh discovering a lot
was going on with claudian gay and her
plagiarism and Victor Davis Hansen a
senior fellow at the Hoover institution
Chris as I said you're one of the big
reasons why Miss Gay's plagiarism was
exposed and why this you know this is a
win that she's out of this
position there's so much more to be
discussed and to be rooted out out here
is there
not yeah that's right certainly this was
my initial goal to uh topple president
gay from the presidency of Harvard uh
but Harvard has to go much further
Harvard needs to abolish its Dei
programs it needs to put a permanent end
to its racist admission system uh it
needs to pledge institutional neutrality
on controversial political issues and it
needs to diversify The Faculty not on
skin color uh but on uh philosophy on
political belief on viewpoints uh that's
really what Harvard needs to do to start
rebalancing the institution our
reporting on claudian Gay's plagiarism
on her Dei Empire and on her absolutely
botched handling of the campus anti-em
anti-Semitism controversy shows that the
institutions are are weak their ideology
is a failure uh and we're just getting
started in this campaign for reform yeah
Victor I think it's important that uh
people don't claim like a premature
Victory here Al while this is very
important that's why I decided to do the
show tonight very very important this is
just one person at one University that
happens to be Harvard but tell us about
what you know about how deep this really
goes in the American educational
psyche well it's institutionalized and
people who speak out against it are
punished and they have a they have a
fundamental contradiction lorea because
they all claim their pre and they're
hyper mraic and they're not and they
they base decisions on hiring and
retention and scholarship and admissions
on race and then when you're lying like
that then the lies are not the end they
begin so in this case with gay she lied
unfortunately to say that but numerous
times she said that she had uh been
proactive about the plagiarism she was
always reactive she never was proactive
she said that she had the highest
standards of scholarship her whole life
she started this data misinformation and
plagiarism plagiarism when she was a a
graduate student writing her
dissertation she said that she couldn't
speak out against anti-Semitism because
of the First Amendment she speaks about
everything and violates the First
Amendment anytime it's any question
other than anti-Semitism and then she
said she even brought up the race card
as did the Harvard Corporation when race
was a reason that she was hired not
because she was fired right and then the
the corporation really disgraced
themselves they played the race card and
then they they kind of made made a snark
about it got out in the public domain
we're the public domain we were the ones
that give them a tax exempt uh endowment
income we're the ones that give them
millions of dollars in federal research
we're the ones that give guaranteed
student loans and all of a sudden
they're snarky about the public domain
as if we're Hicks or something they're
really arrogant well Chris what's
stunning to some but not to probably us
is that it's not like she's separated
from the University she loses the top
job but she remains
Chris yeah you know the left takes care
of its own so she will be demoted back
down to a professorship at Harvard
she'll be allowed to retain that for now
although there are some serious
questions that this plagiarism the sheer
quantity 40 plus instances of plagiarism
could also jeopardize her tenure could
also jeopardize her professorship but
the real thing to understand Laura is
that as conservatives uh it's not just
about uh getting rid of Claud gay as
president of Harvard it's about
reshaping the incentives around Elite
culture uh Harvard's Corporation board
members are Craven individuals they will
blow whichever way the wind blow
whichever way the wind goes and so it's
important that we are the wind that we
take control of the set of cultural
incentives that determine the elite
consensus if we can change that if we
can uh shame people when they need to be
shamed if we could encourage people
where they need to be encouraged uh we
can start to reformulate these in
institions that as Dr Hansen said uh so
gracefully have been institutionalized
with this Dei ideology well Victor also
the whole diversity equity and inclusion
movement is intertwined with
anti-americanism
and um I think
anti-Semitism the BLM was kind of part
of this very Marxist roots and and this
is sadly what's what's come of these
once incredible and still in some ways
great institutions yet badly badly
damaged I mean for self-preservation
they've got to ditch this
stuff yeah but they can't because
they're so wetted to it so all they do
is keep lying and so what do you do when
you say that Dei is not racist you start
to have racist segregated graduations
racist segregated safe spaces racist
segregated dorms and then they have to
come up with this orwellian language to
hide the lies they call them theme
houses when they're segregated or did
you notice Laura when they were
plagiarizing they went first to
duplicative language and now they
they've even gone beyond that and called
it missteps missteps yeah and now they
have this lie that they're going to be
stuck with a professor who's a
plagiarist when they're expelling 40 or
50 students or disciplin them for far
less egregious plagiarism that's not if
you dress know yeah guys if you dress up
as an Indian on Thanksgiving and you're
like a member of the lacrosse team I
mean you're lucky to get a job after
school in some of these places right but
you're the president of Harvard just oh
you can you have a chance to kind of
correct this and we're going to move on
well that didn't work out Chris and
Victor both of you are so important in
this discussion thank you so much hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else